[Music]
we're getting married
wait a minute what skateboard boy hello
i think this is the place this is it hey
youtube
shut up and take our money oh
this backyard shut up and take our money
what's the catch
are you guys here for the party this is
tommy lee's sex swing
hell no i just don't feel comfortable
allowing some weirdo to live in our
guest house me
jesus that's not a kid come with me
he'll be out soon i will march up there
and i'll see you gotta get out of here
three months i don't know about you
[Music]
the drug is called flakka some are
calling it the insanity
can't do that in my house
you need anything no you're good just
some space
did you have a talk with randy today i
yeah yeah
hello whoa whoa whoa
you're high no i'm not you're honest
just get rid of the guys
welcome to the neighborhood you haven't
been arrested no you got you arrested it
is
so odd
i totally forgot to tell you they're bug
bombing the house today
here we go flock opossums
we just wanted a house and we found this
one and then you
we'd be millionaires right now
[Music]
you